on va essayer celle-là dernier
accrochage dernière mise en place sylvie
des moulins pose sur ses murs 20 ans de
peinture
elle a longtemps été architecte une
rencontre un bébé elle change de vie et
se consacre alors à la peinture
elle regarde sa fille grandir lassus à
l'école au cours de danse
on est transporté dans cet univers où il
ya des choses
séduisante des maladresses de
l'application pour apprendre quelques
fois des moments tristesse enfin tous
les moments de la vie de l'enfant
et quand on a eu soi même la chance
d'avoir une enfance heureuse
on revit avec bonheur tous ces moments
[Musique]
des souvenirs d'enfance qui lui
reviennent en mémoire
alors que les ti mobilisés après une
chute il en sortira cette série de
portraits de paysages avec ses couleurs
et cette lumière si caractéristique des
pays du maghreb
j'ai travaillé bien sûr avec mes
souvenirs tomber souvenirs j'ai
travaillé avec des photos beaucoup de
photos que mes parents ma portaient des
objets également qu'ils ont apporté aux
maires de rapporter des ustensiles de
cuisine le couscous il par exemple le
bon et avec j'ai un peu fait feu de tout
bois tout ce qu'ils pouvaient ranimer un
souvenir
je vais utiliser
sylvie des moulins pas la vie celle du
quotidien celle de tout un chacun
elle y met ses émotions et ses passions
chacun peut se reconnaître dans sa
peinture
[Musique]